now just yesterday a leader from
yesterday began a campaign for president
by promising to take us back to
yesterday yesterday is over
and we're never going back we must
change the decisions we are making by
changing the people who are making them
and so that is why tonight grounded by
the lessons of our history but inspired
by the promise of our future I announce
my candidacy for president of the United
I've heard some suggest that I should
step aside and wait my turn
but I cannot because I believe our very
identity as an exceptional nation is at
stake and I can make a difference as
president the final verdict on our
generation will be written by Americans
who have not yet been born let us make
sure they record that we made the right
choice that in the early years of this
century faced with a rapidly changing
and uncertain world
our generation rose to face the great
challenges of our time and because we
did because we did there was still one
place in the world where you were who
you come from does not determine how far
you go because we did because we did the
American miracle lived on because we did
our children and theirs lived in a new
American Century thank you God bless you
god bless the United States thank you
you